[Musique]
les histoires terrier oui il ya des gens
qui y vivent normalement tout va bien et
tout ils jouent au loto et manque de
chance ils gagnent ils se prennent une
overdose de bonne heure le train du
bonheur sa place dans la tête
caceis afu une vie en l'air
démonstration avec un reportage tourné
près d'epinal regarder un numéro j'en
vois tu jean-louis trop j'envoie khiate
j'envoie 5 j'envoie 6 roger girard qui
travaille au rayon poissonnerie de la
coop de golbey près d'epinal a gagné au
loto
232 millions de centimes un numéro
j'en vois que jean louis 3 mais le
destin lui aussi a coché trois cases
résultat trois morts le frère le père et
roger girard lui même
quant à la mère pioche le désespoir seul
et bien désemparés elle ne veut plus
voir personne et se demande encore ce
qui s'est passé un numéro genre du
collège pas tomber
c'est vous madame qui avait validé le
bulletin de roger-gérard c'était un
joueur régulier qui faisait valider
chaque semaine sept bulletins à 7 est
alors porté chance le 5 novembre 77
roger-gérard apprend qu'il a gagné 2 132
millions il rentre chez sa mère jean luc
son frère chômeurs et jaloux il trouve
aussi que c'est injuste et se jette sous
le train
[Musique]
un numéro aux gérard qui ne buvait que
de l'eau fait entrer à la maison des
plaques offre deux mercedes de champagne
et de whisky comme pour les riches il
fait goûter à son père le père tout ça
bon un an plus tard il meurt d'une
cirrhose du foie
deux morts en voitures
roger girard qui commencent à trouver
que l'addition est lourde continuent
d'arroser sa chance mais avec de plus en
plus de désenchantement
il écrase aussi contre des arbres cette
mercedes tellement ils ne distinguent
plus bien la route de sa vie la route
qui mène au casino de vittel où il perd
de plus en plus les rares fois où il
gagne au lieu de faire changer l'argent
il fait monter les plaques de 100 sacs
en porte clés et les distribuer à tout
le monde
j'imagine que je commette à roger que
d'autres à qui ça peut arriver
ce 3 ce qu elle était une fortune aux
siens pourtant peuvent se laisser griser
et peut aussi se laisser impressionner
par des des propositions qui leurs sont
faites par des gens peu scrupuleux qui
les entoure des gens peu scrupuleux et
des faux amis quémandeurs roger en
rencontres tous les soirs dans les
boîtes de nuit où il va avec sa mère il
perd ici ces dernières liasses de
billets
[Musique]
prendre trois 3 morts
roger-gérard seul écoeuré ruine et meurt
dans la misère d'une cirrhose du foie
cinq ans après avoir gagné presque jour
pour jour
24e ont bousculé la peur 25e 26e
en fait la chance à porter 232 millions
mais elle avait aussi trois morts caché
derrière son dos voilà et tout ça c'est
rien que la vérité c'est une histoire
vraie ce qu'on a vu c'est bien roger
gérard c'était en 81 dossiers de l'écran
voilà c'est un reportage très moral qui
dit que l'argent fait pas le bonheur
[Musique]